architecture is amazing for sure it's
amazing because is art but you know it's
a very funny kind of art is it not the
frontier between art and science it's
fitted by my real life every day it's
driven by force of necessity quite
amazing quite amazing and the life of
the architect is also amazing you know
as an architect at 10 o clock in the
morning you need to be a poet for sure
but at eleven you must become a humanist
otherwise you lose your direction and at
noon you absolutely need to be a builder
you need to be able to make building
because access then is the art of making
buildings architecture is the art of
making shelter for human beings period
and this is not easy at all it's amazing
look at this here we are in London at
the top of the shard of glass is a
building that we have complete few years
ago those people are well trained
workers and they are selling the top
piece of the tower well they they look
like rock climbers they are I mean they
are defying the force of gravity like
building does by the way we got 30 of
those people actually on the site we got
more than 1400 people coming from 60
different nationalities into this
miracle
is a miracle to put together 50 14 and
people coming from so different places
is a miracle site are miracles is
another one let's talk about
construction adventure it's adventure in
real life not in virtue in spirit this
guy there is a deep water diver from
rock climber to deep deep water divers
this is in Berlin after the fall of the
wall in 89 we built this building
collecting is burning to West Berlin in
put summer plans we got on that project
almost 5000 people almost 5000 people
and this is not a site in Japan building
the Kansai Airport again all the rock
climber Japanese one in the begin
building together is the best way to
create the sense of cooperation the
sense of pride pride Association but you
know construction of course is one of
the reason why extension amazing but
there is another one that is maybe even
more amazing because architecture is the
art of making shelter for communities
not just for individuals communities and
the society at large and society is
never to say the world keeps changing
and changes are difficult to swallow by
people and architecture is a mirror of
those changes architecture is the built
expression of those changes so this is
why it is so difficult because those
changes create adventure
it creates invention our search is a
friendship this is the salt resultant
between Paris long time ago that balls
back in time 77 this was a spaceship
landing in the middle of Paris together
with my friend in adventure with Rogers
we were at that time young bad boys
young bad boys
it was really only few years after may
68 so it was better William pure
rebellion the idea was to make the proof
that culture building should not be
intimidating they should create a sense
of curiosity this is the way to create
the culture place callosity is the
beginning of a cultural attitude and
there is a place where you can see that
Piazza and Plaza is the beginning of the
urban life a plazas the place where
people meet and the mix experience and
the mix ages and you know in some way
you create the the essence of the city
and since then we made the office so
many of the places for people here in
Rome is a concept all another place for
people this building on inside is
actually designed by the sound you can
see it's flirting with sound and this is
the Kansai Airport in Japan to make a
billion sometimes you need to make an
island then we made the island the
believes of more than one night long it
looked like an immense glider landing on
ground and this is in San Francisco
another place for people this building
is the California Cardinal science and
we planted on that roof thousand
thousand plants that they use the
humidity of the air
instead of pumping water from the water
table and the roof is a linear fracture
and this building was made platinum lead
the lead is the system to measure of
course bill sustainability of building
so this was also a place for people that
will stay long time and this is actually
New York this is the new Whitney at the
mid-market
District in New York well another flying
vessel another place for people yeah we
are noting the Niarchos foundation is a
library it's a opera house concert hall
a park a bit park this building is also
a platinum LEED this building this
building actually captured the Sun
energy by that roof but you know make it
build in place for people it's good
making libraries making concert hall
making universities making museum it's
good because you create place open
accessible you create building for
battle wall for sure but there is
something else that make architects
amazing even more and this is the fact
that architecture doesn't just answer to
need a necessity but also to desires yes
desires dreams aspirations this is what
architects does even the most modest art
on earth is not just roof small dinner
roof is telling a story is telling story
about the identity of people living in
that art individual architecture is the
art of telling stories like this one
in Londo the shot of glass but this
building is the tallest building in the
Western Europe it goes up more than 300
meter in the air to breathe fresh air
the facets of this building
I mean Clinard and they reflect the sky
wrong that is never the same after rain
everything become bluish in the sunny
evening everything is right it's
something that is difficult to explain
it's what we call the soul of a building
on this picture on the left you have the
mini collection used on long time ago is
a museum on the right is the other Art
Museum both of those two been in flirt
with light light is probably one of the
most essential material in architecture
and this is in Amsterdam this building
is flirting with water and this is by
office on the sea well this is flirting
with work actually enjoy work in there
and that cable car is Delta cable car
that goes up to them that's the New York
Times in New York well this is playing
with transparency against the sense of
light a sense of transparency on the
left here you have a magic lantern in
Japan in Ginza in Tokyo and in the
center is a monastery in the forest this
is their monasteries playing with the
silence and the forest and the museum
Science Museum this is about levitation
and this is the set of Paris and the
belly of the whale this is the Patti
Foundation in Paris well all those
building has something in common is that
something is a searching for
desire for dreams and that's me
but it's me on my sailing boat and
flirting with breeze it's not a very
good reason to show you this picture I'm
trying I'm trying you know
well one is clear I love sailing for
sure I actually also love designing
sailing boat but I love sailing because
selling is associated with slowness and
in silence and the sense of suspension
and there is knowledge in that this
picture says says that I am Italian and
there was very little I can do about
that
I'm the tire and I love beauty I love
beauty
well let's go sailing I want to take you
sailing air to this place in the middle
of the Pacific Ocean it's visitors
Germany global center is for the canal
key ethnic group is in umeå New
Caledonia this place is for art of
nature and those building actually flirt
with the wind with the trade winds they
have a sound they have a voice those
building I am showing this because is
about beauty is about to build and let's
talk about beauty for a moment beauty is
like the bird of paradise but the right
moment you try to catch it it flies away
your arm is too short but beauty is not
the frivolous idea is there opposite in
my native language that is trying a
beautiful is Bello Bello in Spanish
beauty is belief in Greek beautiful is
jealous when you add a guitars that mean
beautiful and good and no one of those
language beautiful just mean beautiful
it also mean good real beauty is when
the invisible join visible Tammy on
surface and this doesn't apply only to
art nature this applies to science human
curiosity solidarity that's reason why
you may say this is a beautiful person
there's a beautiful mind this this is
the beauty that can change people in
better people
by switching a patient light in their
eyes and make him building for this
beauty makes a city better places to
live and better cities make better
citizen now this beauty this universal
beauty I should say is one of the few
things that can change the world
believe me this beauty will save the war
one person at the time but it will do it
thank
[Applause]